back it's time for pop quiz yes
okay
where is audience member sidonie francis
hello what a great name right siddonia
look at you spring has sprung yes you
know i had to get out that seasonal
depression
i know it's true color changes
everything it really elevates the mood
[Applause]
i hope you've been paying attention all
so long i hope i have too all right
we're going to ask you some questions
about today's show and if you get all
three right you're gonna win
a thousand dollars
all right okay all right good luck to
you thank you
good luck to you okay first question
netflix's upcoming biopic blonde is
about
what famous actress
and then later this year netflix is also
releasing their highly anticipated
biopic blonde with anna diarmas and
she's playing marilyn marilyn monroe
that's right that's right
you gotta get the next two right here's
question number two judd apatow was just
on he and he said he was once roommates
as one of drew's frequent co-stars
who was now you were roommates with adam
sandler yes yes i was oh i know this one
adam sandler that's right
[Applause]
get in here get in here okay as we get
nervous we get closer together i'm
getting nervous too because i'm moving
and i really want a thousand dollars for
my new couch okay oh i want you to win
so bad okay all you need to do is answer
this final question right are you ready
okay
who did bridget monahan play
in sex in the city i've loved you in so
many different iterations and films and
movies and characters but gosh let's
kick it off with natasha i mean sex in
the city uh
you're so incredible as natasha
oh my god
um
natasha natasha big second life
[Applause]
oh
nailed it i never watched sex in the
city because i was too young when it
aired so my mom didn't let me watch it
not a bad idea to not watch it as a kid
but i will say you should sit down on
your new couch and binge it
you also i'm gonna match it with a
thousand dollar um gift card to like
let's say cb2
true yes
that's happening my
chest so
good luck in your new apartment sit on
that fabulous new cb2 couch i love cb2
enjoy that cash
and definitely binge sex in the city
[Applause]
[Music]
you